en quelques heures nous avons aperçu une
vingtaine d'automobilistes traversé
illégalement la voie camilien-houde la
mort d'un cycliste le 4 octobre sur le
mont royal a poussé l'administration
plantes à revoir la présence des
voitures à cet endroit
le 2 juin la ville a lancé un projet
pilote interdisant l'accès d'un segment
qui traverse la montagne vous savez que
vous avez pas de traverser camilien
houde
non je peux aider nos dates à la brigade
out
non et non ouais j'ai entendu ça que
vous faites ici à l'art malgré une
nouvelle signalisation et des campagnes
de sensibilisation les automobilistes
qui circulent toujours
la police de montréal a remis 556
constat depuis le 2 juin soit une
moyenne de 7 par jour
le montant de la contravention 149
dollars savez vous n'avez pas le droit
d'être ici je suis un über mamie
voitures taxis et les conducteurs
d'hubert sont interdits seuls les
piétons les vélos véhicules d'urgence
les autobus les véhicules d'entretien de
la ville et les cortèges funéraires ont
le droit passage j'aime bien
l'aménagement cette part où je pense que
c'est auprès de près non non c'est en
ukraine est tranquille c'est bien avant
le projet pilote plus de 10000 véhicule
emprunté la voie camilien-houde
quotidiennement pour vélo québec
l'important est qu'ils aient cycliste
est retrouvé une certaine quiétude sur
la montagne et surtout qu'il n'y ait pas
eu d'accident depuis ça permet quand
même de voir ce que peut être le chemin
camilien houde
quand il ya moins de trafic est-ce que
des amendes est ce que les ajustements
oui et là
façon en place a mis sur place une
consultation publique vous avez jusqu'à
novembre pour vous prononcer l'office de
consultation publique de montréal a été
mandatée pour étudier le projet pilote
doit prendre fin le 31 octobre
il doit remettre son rapport début 2019
ici marie laurence de l'aîné radio
canada montréal